y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el pasado mes de enero la policía de
indonesia golpeó violentamente a este
grupo de refugiados a sara una minoría
oprimida en afganistán los azares llevan
años emigrando a indonesia con la
esperanza de luego obtener asilo en
otros países como eeuu y australia pero
tras el suicidio de una sarah llamados a
pep balkin el 16 de enero la ira de esta
minoría se intensificó este hombre
llevaba seis años esperando ser
reubicado y no podía trabajar ni enviar
a sus cinco hijos a la escuela hablamos
con algunos de sus compañeros refugiados
en una llamada grupal
[Música]
fuimos a la oficina de acnur porque
perdimos a uno de nuestros refugiados a
sara que se suicidó
vamos allá a pedir ayuda pero la policía
nos golpeó muy fuerte mis hombres
resultaron heridos y están en el
hospital golpearon a mujeres y a niños
a mí también me hirieron y duele la
espalda y también la rodilla
a uno de nuestros amigos lo hicieron en
la cabeza
h
indonesia no hace parte de la convención
de ginebra de 1951 sobre el estatuto de
los refugiados esto significa que los
refugiados pueden permanecer en el país
hasta que otros estados los acepten no
se les permite trabajar ni estudiar así
que lo único que pueden hacer es esperar
prefiriendo alguien más pero vamos de
alicante a
los refugiados llegan aquí casi una
década
vivir diez años sin familia no es fácil
y también sin trabajo sin derechos
fundamentales la situación se tornó aún
más difícil para los a sara de indonesia
cuando el grupo talibán tomó nuevamente
el poder en afganistán el pasado mes de
agosto
y evaluar la situación de los refugiados
empeoró aún más el ya que la mayoría de
sus familias corren peligro en
afganistán los asadas son una minoría y
siempre han sido blanco de los salones
de
baile para los pasará también son
discriminados en indonesia por ser una
minoría son musulmanes chiitas en un
país en donde el 99% de la población es
sunita
es un orden de thiers
ayudante hace más de ocho años que no
practico mi religión porque tengo miedo
y si lo hago vendrán a matarme
tengo el cam en tubo
[Música]
no hay esperanza en el futuro aquí nada
está claro
y perdemos nuestra energía día a día nos
debilitamos cada día estamos más
desesperados
la gente se está muriendo ya los que
cometen estos crímenes contra estas
mujeres vulnerables no se les hace
responsables por qué ocurre esto nuestro
observador se llama david cambio jet de
sudán del sur y es uno de los 600.000
migrantes bloqueados en libia que sueña
con llegar a europa junto a otro millar
de migrantes formó parte del campamento
improvisado que fue instalado a finales
del 2021 frente a una agencia del alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas para
los refugiados en trípoli la capital de
libia
ahí es donde estos hombres y mujeres se
habían reunido tras ser expulsados de
sus hogares en una brutal operación de
las fuerzas de seguridad de libia pero
con tanta gente agolpándose en las
puertas la agencia ya no podía funcionar
el 10 de enero cerró y trasladó sus
operaciones a otro lugar y fue ese día
cuando la policía de libia llevó a cabo
una operación allí
las fuerzas de seguridad están llegando
solo por los migrantes solo por los
migrantes
nuestro observador documento en vídeo la
represión de las fuerzas de seguridad
libias en su cuenta de twitter
[Música]
cuando llegó la policía y los vehículos
se generó tensión la gente tenía miedo
bloquearon la entrada y la salida de la
calle incluso les bloquearon el paso los
ciudadanos sus vidrios no había autos en
la calle excepto los vehículos militares
las tensiones aumentaron y los guardias
libios armados disparaban al aire y a la
gente y destruían las carpas
empezaron a golpear a la gente con sus
armas
en plena acción algunas personas
lograron escaparse y a quienes corrían
los militares y las fuerzas armadas les
disparaban
estas personas fueron acorraladas
atacadas y vo empleadas los obligaron a
subir a unos buses y se los llevaron a
diferentes lugares algunos a centros de
detención
la mayoría de los refugiados están ahora
detenidos en galicia no tienen acceso a
los baños no tienen cobijas de colchones
para dormir es una especie de tortura y
la violación de los derechos humanos no
se puede describir algo tan no
imaginable
han pasado tres semanas desde que estos
migrantes fueron llevados al centro de
detención de aín zará ellos describen
este lugar como un sitio atestado donde
no tienen suficiente comida y esperan
ser evacuados muy pronto a europa
es todo por esta semana de los
observadores de france 24 recuerde si
quieren comunicarse con la producción
del programa lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales ya los números
de contacto que aparecen en sus
pantallas nos vemos la próxima semana
hasta pronto